♪ ♪
>> Laura: I'M LAURA INGRAHAM
AND THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE"
ON A VERY BUSY FRIDAY NIGHT SO
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
HURRICANE IAN IS NOT DONE YET
AFTER A STAGGERING IN SOUTHWEST
FLORIDA THE STORM IS MOVING UP
THE EAST COAST.
WE WILL HAVE REPORTS FROM BOTH
LOCATIONS IN THE HOUR.
WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH A
DIFFERENT KIND OF DEVASTATION,
NOT THE TYPE OF COST BY
MOTHER NATURE BUT BY CORRUPT MEN
AND WOMEN.
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE ECONOMIC
DAMAGE DONE BY THOSE WHO SCANNED
THE AMERICAN TAXPAYERS DURING
THE PANDEMIC.
THIS IS A STORY THAT UNFOLDS IN
THREE PARTS.
FIRST, THE FRAUD.
JUST YESTERDAY WE LEARNED THAT
NEARLY 400 DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY EMPLOYEES TOOK
PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT AID, EVEN
THOUGH THEY WERE WORKING.
THIS IS JUST A TINY FRACTION OF
THE MASSIVE AND BRAZEN COVID
THEFT THAT HAS INCURRED SINCE
THE GOVERNMENT STARTED DOLING
OUT BILLIONS IN SO-CALLED
RELIEF.
THE OFFICIAL WHO WAS IN CHARGE
OF OVERSEEING THE DISTRIBUTION
OF THE BELIEF HAS CALLED THIS
THE BIGGEST FRAUD IN A
GENERATION.
IT WAS THE THEFT OF AS MUCH AS
$80 BILLION OR ABOUT 10% OF THE
$800 BILLION IT WAS HANDED OUT
IN THAT PAYCHECK PROTECTION
PROGRAM.
THAT'S ON TOP OF THE 90 BILLION
TO 402 BILLION BELIEVED TO HAVE
BEEN STOLEN FROM THE 900 BILLION
COVID UNEMPLOYMENT RELIEF
PROGRAM, THAT IS A LOT OF MONEY.
THE SECOND PART OF THIS STORY
SURROUNDS THE TITLE WAVE OF
INFLATION BUT ALL OF THIS
UNCHECKED SPENDING AND THE FRAUD
ACTUALLY CAUSED.
THE ADVERSE EFFECTS OF PUMPING
TRILLIONS INTO THE U.S. ECONOMY
WITH NO SAFEGUARDS.
THE FED PREDICTED THAT THE
COVERT STIMULUS ALONE IS DRIVING
30% OF THE CURRENT INFLATIONARY
EFFECTS.
THAT MEANS ALL OF THOSE BIG, FAT
FRAUDS SITTING AT THEIR MEXICAN
RESORTS DURING COVID COLLECTING
THEIR CHECKS, ZOOMING INTO
MEETINGS, ORDERING THEIR TESLA'S
WITH THEIR COVID DOWN PAYMENTS
HELPED CAUSE THE INFLATION MESS
THAT WE ARE IN NOW.
THE THIRD PART OF THIS STORY IS
ABOUT THE OTHER OPPORTUNISTS,
THE SO-CALLED PUBLIC SERVANTS.
ENDED UP USING THE NATIONAL
SUFFERING TO BUILD THE OWN BRAND
WHILE THEY PADDED THE INVESTMENT
PORTFOLIO.
I'M TALKING FIRST ABOUT
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI WHO
PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOULD HAVE
NEVER PUT IN CHARGE OF OUR
COVERT RESPONSE.
LOOKING BACK ON THE ENTIRE SAGA
WE SEE ALL ALONG IT WAS ALL
ABOUT TONY.
THE COVER OF IN STYLE, A PLACE
ON TIMES 100 MOST INFLUENTIAL
DOCUMENTARIES, ALL THE PROFILES.
WHO COULD FORGET THE CHILDREN'S
BOOKS?
HE WANTS YOU TO BELIEVE THIS
FAME THING WAS NEVER ANYTHING HE
ASKED FOR.
>> I DIDN'T SEEK IT OUT BUT I
BECAME THE SYMBOL FOR PEOPLE
WHICH MADE IT AN UNREALISTIC --
THEY ARE KIND OF CUTE BUT IT'S
BOBBLEHEADS AND CANDLES AND
THINGS LIKE THAT.
>> DO YOU HAVE SOME AT HOME?
>> THEY SEND THEM TO ME.
[LAUGHTER]
WHAT I'VE LEARNED TO DO IS NOT
GET TAKEN AWAY EGO WISE.
>> Laura: SO GROSS.
FROM THE BEGINNING OF THE WHOLE
PANDEMIC I HAD MY DOUBTS.
YOU'RE SATISFIED WITH ALL OF THE
TRANSPARENCY COMING OUT OF CHINA
TODAY ABOUT THE TRAJECTORY OF
THE DISEASE AND THE ORIGIN OF
THE DISEASE.
>> MY DIRECT INTERACTION WITH
CHINESE SCIENTISTS AND A CHINESE
HEALTH OFFICIALS, I CAN BELIEVE
WHAT THEY ARE TELLING ME.
>> Laura: I'M SURPRISED HE
WOULD SAY THAT GIVEN WHAT WE
KNOW ABOUT CHINA'S PATTERN OF
LYING ABOUT CRITICAL ISSUES,
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO
DR. FAUCI'S EXPERTISE, NO ONE
ELECTED HIM TO ANYTHING.
>> Laura: NOW WE SEE MY EARLY
SUSPICIONS, HIS SUCKING UP TO
CHINA AND HIS ENTIRE LOCKDOWN
APPROACH PROVED TO BE ON TARGET.
IT WASN'T UNTIL MAY OF THIS YEAR
THAT WE BEGAN TO UNDERSTAND THE
OTHER WAYS THAT HE WAS
BENEFITING.
THAT'S WHEN OUR FRIENDS AT OPEN
THE BOOKS PUBLISHED THIS
BOMBSHELL -- BETWEEN FISCAL YEAR
2010 AND 2020 MORE THAN
350 MILLION IN ROYALTIES WERE
PAID BY THIRD PARTIES TO THE
AGENCY AND NIH SCIENTISTS WHO
WERE CREDITED AS COINVENTORS,
WELL-KNOWN SCIENTISTS RECEIVING
PAYMENTS DURING THE PERIOD
INCLUDED ANTHONY FAUCI WHO
RECEIVED A 23 ROYALTY PAYMENTS.
WHEN HE WAS ASKED ABOUT THIS, HE
TRIED TO DISMISS THE CONCERNS.
>> CAN YOU TELL ME THAT YOU HAVE
NOT RECEIVED A ROYALTY FROM ANY
ENTITY THAT YOU EVER OVERSAW THE
DISTRIBUTION OF MONEY IN
RESEARCH GRANTS?
>> I DON'T KNOW THIS FOR A FACT
BUT I DOUBT IT.
ACCORDING TO THE REGULATIONS,
PEOPLE WHO RECEIVE ROYALTIES ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO DIVULGE THEM
EVEN ON THEIR FINANCIAL
STATEMENT.
>> Laura: IF THERE'S NOTHING
TO HIDE, WHY THE SECRECY?
HOW SELF-SATISFIED HE ALWAYS
COMES ACROSS.
TONIGHT WE MIGHT HAVE FURTHER
PROOF AS TO WHY.
THE SAME OPEN THE BOOK'S GROUP
THAT UNCOVERED THE NIH ROYALTY
PAYMENTS PUBLISHED THIS.
HIS NET WORTH INCREASED BY A
WHOPPING 65% OR $5 MILLION
DURING A THREE-YEAR PERIOD OF
TIME THAT INCLUDES 2021.
IN OTHER WORDS DURING THE
PANDEMIC.
AS THE ELDERLY WERE LEFT TO DIE
ALONE BECAUSE OF COVERT RULES HE
SUPPORTED AS CHILDREN WERE BEING
ROBBED OF THEIR EDUCATION
BECAUSE OF CLOSURES THAT HE
SUPPORTED AND AS YOU WERE
MISSING CHURCH AND WEDDINGS AND
GRADUATIONS BECAUSE OF THE EDICT
THAT THE TASK FORCE WANTED IN
PLACE, HE WAS GETTING RICH.
LAST WEEK DR. FAUCI SAID THE
SCHOOL CLOSURES WERE WORTH IT.
I WONDER IF HE HAS SPOKEN TO
FOLKS LIKE THESE.
>> CHILDREN IN OUR CITIES, MANY
OF WHOM ARE MISSING
OPPORTUNITIES.
>> IT'S BEEN ABYSMAL.
WHO LOBBIES FOR THE
SINGLE-PARENT?
>> WHO LOBBIES FOR THE CHILDREN?
>> Laura: NOT ANTHONY FOUND
SHE.
HE ONLY HAD TIME TO LOBBY FOR
HIMSELF.
JOINING ME NOW IS THE CEO AND
FOUNDER OF OpenTheBooks.com
AND JASON CHAFFETZ FORMER HOUSE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE CHAIR AND
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
YOU SAY GETTING THESE DOCUMENTS
HAS BEEN A PAINSTAKING PROCESS,
WHY IS NIH SLOW WALKING IT'S?
>> IT'S BEEN A KNOCKDOWN, DRAG
OUT DOG FIGHT TO GET THE
FINANCIALS.
WITH OUR LEGAL PARTNERS AT
JUDICIAL WATCH WE HAD TO FILE A
FEDERAL LAWSUIT TO GET FINANCIAL
DISCLOSURES ON FAUCI FROM 15
THROUGH 2020.
ON TUESDAY WE FINALLY GOT THE
2021 FINANCIAL DISCLOSURES, IT
WAS THE LATEST THEY HAD EVER
BEEN PRODUCED AND IN SOME YEARS
THEY USED TO COME OUT IN
FEBRUARY.
HE HAD THESE DONE IN MAY.
THE LATEST THEY HAVE EVER
PRODUCED THEM AS AUGUST.
ON TUESDAY THEY FINALLY PRODUCE
THEM TO OUR AUDITORS AT
OpenTheBooks.com, IT'S NEARLY
OCTOBER.
>> Laura: THIS IS VERY CURIOUS
FOR SOMEBODY LIKE FAUCI WHO
CLAIMS TO BE A PUBLIC SERVANT,
CARES ABOUT WHAT IS GOOD FOR THE
PEOPLE.
WHEN HE WAS PRESSED ABOUT THIS
BY RAND PAUL, HE GOT VERY TOUCHY
AND DISMISSIVE.
THIS IS VERY DISTURBING.
>> SENATOR PAUL WAS OVER THE
TARGET AND HATS OFF TO OPEN THE
BOOKS BECAUSE I GOT TO TELL YOU,
THIS IS A PERSON WHO HAS WORKED
FOR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR
DECADES AND YET HE HAS BECOME A
MULTIMILLIONAIRE.
HIS WIFE HAPPENS TO BE THE CHIEF
BIOETHICIST FOR THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTES OF HEALTH AND YET HE
HAD TO GET A WAIVER FROM NIH TO
BE ON THE BOARD AND WORKED FOR
McGRAW-HILL AND ALSO EDIT THE
MATERIAL THAT GOES INTO THE
McGRAW-HILL BOOKS, ALL THESE
THINGS THAT GO INTO THE
POCKETBOOK, THEY FEED THE
FAMILY, HOW DO THEY BECOME NORTH
OF $10 MILLION IN NET WORTH WHEN
YOU WORK FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR THE LAST MULTIPLE
DECADES.
IT NEEDS EXPOSURE AND PEOPLE
HAVE GOT TO MAKE SURE THIS
CHANGES.
>> Laura: THERE SHOULD BE NO
ROYALTY PAYMENTS TO PEOPLE WHO
ARE BEING PAID BY THE TAXPAYERS.
YOU'RE GETTING ROYALTY PAYMENTS
FOR HEALTH-RELATED ACTIVITIES
THAT YOU ACTUALLY SERVE TO
REGULATE AND ARE INVOLVED IN?
IF THAT'S NOT HAPPENING, TELL US
WHAT IS HAPPENING.
HERE'S ANOTHER THEFT MORE THAN A
THIRD OF COVID-19 RECOVERY FUNDS
AND 21 DEVELOPING COUNTRIES WERE
SCOOPED UP BY BIG CORPORATIONS.
THOSE ARE FINDINGS THE REPORT
RELEASED WEDNESDAY BY THE
FINANCIAL TRANSPARENCY
COALITION.
EXPLAIN THIS FOR US.
I HAVE TO SAY EVEN I WAS
FLABBERGASTED WHEN I HEARD THAT
FACTOID.
>> THIS IS EXACTLY WHY WE NEED
READ THE BILL LEGISLATION.
EVERYONE CAN COME TO OUR WEBSITE
AND SIGN THE PETITION, WE GET A
72 HOUR LEGISLATIVE TIMEOUT SO
OUR LEGISLATORS WOULD SIMPLY
READ THE BILL.
THE PEOPLE, THE POLITICIANS, THE
PUNDITS SO WE COULD SEE WITHIN
THESE MASSIVE THINGS.
THINK ABOUT THE $2 TRILLION
CARES ACT THAT WAS PASSED AT THE
HEIGHT OF THE PANDEMIC IN MARCH,
APRIL AND NOBODY KNEW WHAT WAS
IN THERE.
UP TO $400 MILLION WORTH OF
INITIAL PAYCHECK PROTECTION
PROGRAM LOANS, 95% OF THOSE
TURNED INTO GRANTS WERE PAID AT
THE COMPANIES OWNED BY THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY.
MARCO RUBIO OUT OF FLORIDA GOT
THAT STOCK ON THE NEXT AID TO
BILL BUT THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO
READ THE BILL.
>> Laura: JASON, YOU WERE
THERE AND I KNOW THIS HAS
HAPPENED SO MANY TIMES YOU WANT
TO PULL YOUR HAIR OUT TO.
I THIS ABOUT CHINA, GETTING ANY
BENEFIT WHATSOEVER.
NANCY PELOSI WAS OUT PRAISING
THIS TODAY, WATCH.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN IT WAS THERE TO MAKE
SURE WE PUT MONEY IN THE POCKET
OF AMERICA'S WORKING FAMILIES
THAT GAY PEOPLE MORE OF A CHANCE
TO REBOUND.
IT WAS ABOUT FAIRNESS.
>> Laura: AND IG REPORT
RELEASED IT SAYS AT ONE POINT
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN WAS
SENDING OUT $200 MILLION IN
FRAUDULENT OR WRONG PAYMENTS
EVERY MONTH.
WHAT DO THE REPUBLICANS HAVE TO
DO TO GET BACK IN CHARGE?
>> LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT WENT
OUT AND WASTE, FRAUD, AND ABUSE.
YOU NEED TO STARVE THE BEAST,
STOP SENDING OUT THIS MONEY
UNTIL YOU CAN ACTUALLY CONTROL
WHAT IS THERE.
THE OTHER THING I WOULD LOVE FOR
THEM TO DO IS THEIR NEED TO BE
TERM LIMITS ON MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS BUT THE NEED TO BE TERM
LIMITS ON THE FEDERAL
BUREAUCRACY.
THOSE PEOPLE IN THOSE HIGHER
ECHELON, THOSE PEOPLE ALSO HAVE
TO HAVE TERM LIMITS BECAUSE
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GET FRESH
AND NEW VOICES AND NEW LOOKS AT
THINGS UNLESS YOU ACTUALLY HAVE
THOSE AS WELL.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE YEARS TO
UNRAVEL THIS BUT THEY HAVE TO
SEND SOME PEOPLE TO JAIL AND ANI
REALLY, REALLY WANT TO SEE THE
LIKES OF JIM JORDAN AND A
SENATOR PAUL AND RON JOHNSON GO
AFTER ANTHONY FAUCI AND HIS WIFE
AND FIGU